(wind rushing)
- Good morning, Believe Nation.
Today, we're going to talk
about how to deal with haters.
Lesson number four is
my personal favorite,
and make sure to stick
around all the way to the end
for some special bonus clips.
And as always, as people are
talking, if they say something
that really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well.
Enjoy!
(uplifting music)
- Well, I love my haters,
because my haters are going
to tell me things my friends
and my family are not going to tell me.
Haters are going to be very,
like, they're haters
because they've studied you.
So, they know a thing or two about you.
And so you can learn from your haters.
It's like, any information
can be recycled,
but I don't allow my haters
to penetrate my spirits.
I don't allow them to
throw me off of my plans.
Like, if I've got a hater, I'm not saying,
"Well, my hater..."
I don't waste time talking about them.
I don't waste time getting engaged
in the stuff that they
want me to get engaged.
I stay focused and do
what I'm supposed to do.
But I listen to them to see,
is there anything they're
saying, that's proper,
that I can adjust?
(chimes)
- There's four things when
someone gives you feedback,
or criticism, however it's intended,
whether ill or positive.
And, so one is, not to take it
in, but to kind of catch it.
I think of it like a catcher's mitt.
If you tell me something,
you come across this way,
I'll grab it, and then I'll
look at it and I'll think,
"Okay, is it true?"
If it's true, cool.
I'll put it in and learn from it.
If I think it's not true,
cool, I'll throw it away.
No harm, no foul.
I'm not going to dwell on it, right?
And I think everybody
needs this in this world,
cause most of us are on social media,
and we're all getting like,
all our thoughts are getting
picked apart all the time.
So we really need this more than ever.
Then the third one, is, you
get it and it's a maybe.
Well, I'm not sure.
You said this about me, I'm not sure.
You know, what do you guys think?
You know, what do you think?
I'll ask my friends and
I'll ask other people
and get some feedback and if it's true,
Cool, maybe I'll learn from it.
If everyone's like,
"This is total nonsense,
ignore that dude."
I throw it out.
But then there's a fourth one.
And this is where the real growth is.
Do you know what the fourth one is?
- I don't.
- The fourth one is, you
get it, you throw it out.
I'm talking to you and then
maybe later I'm talking to you,
I get it, and I'm like,
"No, it's not true."
I throw it out, and then later
I'm talking to someone else,
I get it.
It's the third time it's come back to me
after I've thrown it out, and I'm like,
"Wait, maybe I got to take this thing
"a little more seriously."
And it becomes a maybe.
And then it becomes a yes.
And that's when the big growth thing is,
because you kept ignoring this
thing that was in your face.
So, the best feedback,
like where you really grow,
is you keep getting the same feedback,
you keep dismissing it.
At some point, you say, "Wait,
maybe they have something."
So, one way I do this is,
I get together a group of people,
and we sit together once a week
and talk about the shhh
stuff going on in our lives.
I find group therapy really powerful
because if it's just one on one,
I can just say I disagree with you.
But when four or five people are saying,
"Hey dude, no, you're really
coming off like that."
Or, "You're really having this
problem in your relationship
"and maybe you need to look at it."
And five people are saying it.
It's pretty hard to dismiss them.
- Prince, as he was
taking his last breath,
and this is a big shout-out to Prince,
I'm a huge fan.
I don't think Prince cared
what Billboard Magazine said.
Or what anybody said.
It's just the way it is.
It's the way it is.
And so, if through this plea on this show
on 201 on a Monday in the late spring,
if I could get four of you to understand
it's just not going to matter when people,
I mean, I love when people,
I don't even know what else to tell you,
I'm going to say it very clear.
Let's get very focused here,
because I want to really
deliver this with all the drama
that it deserves.
I like when people put me down.
I get off on when people put me down.
Nothing is more interesting to me
than to prove all of you wrong.
I love the people who
think I'm a huckster,
or I've got some hidden
agenda, or I'm not that good,
or I won't be that great, or
I think too big of myself,
or my dad had a liquor store
and that's the only reason I'm
successful, or I got lucky,
or, dut dut dut dut.
Show me.
Please, please, please
continue to judge me
and underestimate me.
Cause it's the only driver I have.
And that's how I'm wired.
And I don't expect all of
you to be wired that way
but if I can, through my
energy, move any of you,
and trust me, I'm reading your comments,
cause your comments are my oxygen,
and I see so many of you,
so many comments over the
last three or four months,
of people saying,
"Hum, I've got a little more cockiness
"or confidence then I used to."
As a matter of fact, I see it in you guys.
I truly see my inner
circle have more confidence
when they're around.
It just rubs off.
Indeed, you're getting cocky.
- I probably am.
- [Gary] Have you felt it?
- Yeah.
I think confident is what I prefer.
- I know, I know, I know.
But, it's true, right?
There's a rub-off.
It's kind of like a
leader on a sports team.
It rubs off.
And one of the great
accomplishments in my life,
will be the fact that I was
able to rub off my confidence,
not only on my inner circle,
but on the community
that decided to give me.
It's unbelievable how good
I feel that I get to reward,
the amazing reward that you give me.
Which is, in all the
things that you could be
watching right now, you're watching this.
In all the things you could be reading.
Spending time on.
Time.
You've decided to watch me.
Me!
Do you know how incredibly
empowering that is?
And it's that scale.
It's not three people.
Do you know how empowering that is?
And for me,
knowing that not only do I
give you tactical advice,
or in a funny way that I
answer question number three,
a girl in Indonesia might say,
"Well, if Gary Vee is bad at
math and has been successful,
"I can too."
Or, in this ending rant, you
can care a little bit less
what your coworker or your older brother
or that naysayer says.
Or, what I know so many of you deal with,
which is, the trolling and the hate,
and the disagreeing,
even when it's done well.
And I love when people disagree with me
in the comment section.
I take it for what it is.
Even when that happens.
Do you know how pissed
I was at Daily Vee 30?
How many people emphatically
were drilling me for a bad episode?
Fine.
But like, after all, and
that's fine and I agree,
and we didn't do a good
job setting that up,
and I don't think I set
up D-Rock for success.
It's a genre that he's
not as passionate about.
I could've done a better job.
I understand that.
But, it blows me away,
how much venom people
can put of like,
like after you provide,
you're only as good as your last ep back.
200 great episodes of a business show.
30 great episodes of a docu show.
5,000 interviews of business stuff.
Unbelievable engagement.
Answering your questions.
Answering your snaps.
Boom!
One baseball fantasy thing, and
pure and utter disagreement,
disparagement, hate, negativity.
That's hard!
I'm the most confident and it felt bad.
And I didn't like it.
So, what do I expect from others?
I get it.
But it is what it is.
And at the end of the day,
it's not going to matter.
And you have to love yourself first.
And feel good and complete
with yourself first.
So, as a 15-year-old,
I would do what I did as
a 15-year-old, which is,
start building those skills.
And not listen to your parents.
And not listen to your teachers.
And not listen to your friends.
Respect it.
But don't let anybody, anybody
impose their way on you.
It's you.
You're with yourself.
And you've got to make
yourself happy first.
- Don't give away your power.
So, anytime some nasty
criticism or BS comes your way,
you have to say this,
"You cannot take me down.
"I will not give you that power."
I want you to make that
your new mantra in life.
You got to realize that people
can say whatever they want,
but you do not have to take it in
and you don't have to
let it ruin your day.
Your time on this earth is so precious
and it's really, really important
that you protect your soul.
- Empathize.
You know a lot of people who
are being in a negative mood
or negative energy, you don't know why.
You know?
You've had a bad day, too.
You've been rude.
Yes, I know you're amazing
and you watch this show,
and you're really into
personal development,
but at the end of the day,
you've been rude to people too.
You've had a bad day.
You've snapped.
You've been impatient.
You've hollered.
You've been a jerk when
you shouldn't have been.
You know it.
Well, other people do too.
So, when somebody is
negative, always wonder,
"I wonder what happened
today that lead to that."
You know?
Maybe the kids got out
of the wrong side of bed,
and they were just horrible that morning
and that person didn't sleep last night.
Maybe, something happened
with their family.
Maybe, on the way to their work,
they just thought of
something very depressing
in their past.
Maybe, the truth is, right
now they're so unclear
about who they are, and
what they want in life,
that they're taking it
out on other people.
Maybe their own failures,
their own struggles,
their own disappointments
have ravaged them
and led them to depression.
Led them to mental disorder.
The reality is, we never
know someone's story.
And, once you can teach yourself that,
I really believe you
become a better human.
You become more compassionate.
You're better at listening.
You're better able to understand
because you have the intention
to sympathize and say
"Oh, that person's really
in a bad place right now."
You don't take ownership of that.
Say, "Well, I didn't cause it."
You just say simply,
"Ah, they're in a bad
place. I hope they're okay."
I think it's a real, true personal power
to be able to walk by negative people,
and still say,
"I wish you nothing but
joy and health and strength
"and love in your life."
To have that hope for people,
even when they're in a bad
place, that's humanity.
- Your critics don't matter.
Has there ever been a
statue built of a critic?
I remember the great writer
Paulo Coelho said that
he doesn't think about his
critics, that's their job.
And it made me realize
that, that is so true.
You see so many of us.
We spend our time worrying
about people who don't serve us.
I say, I am letting go of
whatever no longer serves me
to make space for what
the hell inspires me.
And that is that
beautiful pirana baby, right?
Now, in the grand scheme
of criticism, right?
We can write essays.
We can write essays on criticism,
because it's so exciting.
Look at it like this,
many people stop having fun,
you play it safe when
someone criticises you.
So when I first started to
make videos, someone said,
"Gosh, Ralph, that video was so long."
It was only four minutes.
So I said,
"Actually, okay.
"I'm going to take on board what you say."
And the next video, the
next video was 26 minutes.
Can I get a hello there?
You see?
I made videos with my
hair all over the place.
And some people said, "Ralph,
your hair looks terrible."
Do you know how I felt?
Yeah, I felt like that.
It was really hard.
And, I thought,
"Okay, I've got to make my hair like this,
"I've got to make my hair like that."
Then I said, "Actually, my
hair does not define who I am.
"I am not my hair.
"I am so much more."
So that gave me the
strength to say, "Screw it."
And for many years,
I made videos
with my hair all over
the place and guess what?
I loved it.
Can I get a hello there?
Do whatever you want.
Say whatever you want.
Go wherever you want.
And if anybody's got a
problem with that, screw them.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
one of my teammates, Ivan,
who does a lot of the
research for these videos,
wanted to put this one together.
So, thank you, Ivan, for all the work.
And if there's a topic
that you'd like us to cover
in the next edition of Believe Life,
please leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'm also curious to figure out
what was the biggest lesson
that you took from this?
How are you having a hard
time dealing with haters?
And maybe,
did one of these strategies
stand out from the rest?
I'm super curious to figure it out.
Leave it in the comments,
your experiences below,
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally, I want to give a
shout-out to my publisher,
Marian Lizzi.
Thank you so much, Marian,
for all your support in
the launch of my book
Your One Word,
and for posting that awesome
unboxing picture on Instagram.
I really, really, really,
really appreciate it.
So thank you guys, again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see you soon.
- I'm one who always welcomes criticism.
And I encourage people, you
should should welcome criticism,
and be bold enough to give criticism.
If the criticism is
coming out of benevolence,
that someone is criticising
so that I can become better,
then it is always welcome.
But if someone is criticising
just out of jealousy
or trying to pull someone
down, then that is not good.
Then that is coming
from a malefic mindset.
So, constructive criticism, I
feel everyone should welcome.
Criticism with compassion.
Criticism with love
is most adorable thing.
And it should always be welcomed.
- Use their energy.
Use that energy they put out there.
Use that challenge for your
own character development.
Really.
See?
When somebody's negative around me,
I don't sit there and I
don't become a victim.
Oh gosh, they're such negative...
I don't go home and assume their energy,
and now I'm negative.
Instead, I go,
"You know what?
"This is a moment to test.
"Am I really in command of
my emotions and how I think?
"Or are they?"
Am I giving my power over to the world,
so that they can just take my energy
and turn it to what they
want or am I in charge?
So I use it as a challenge.
Not as something, I
don't have to challenge
or change them immediately.
I'll get to that point.
But I get to the point where I say,
"You know what?
"Huh, here's a little
challenge the world's
"throwing me right now.
"Can I stay on my game?
"Can I stay centered?
"Can I stay peaceful?
"Can I stay calm?
"Can I stay present, right here, right now
"and not have to run away from it.
"Not have to pretend it's
not there, but use it."
And I encourage you to do that.
Because, if it's just something that you
immediately complain about,
well then, in your complaint
you've just let them win.
Their negativity has turned you into
noticing what is negative and you lost.
You're not winning.
Even if you can critically
throw a barb at it,
make fun of it, you're still losing.
You're being sucked into
their pools of pessimism.
You're drowning.
So I say, use it.
Recognize it and use it.
- Harshest criticism.
Look, the thing is, you
know, in the beginning,
it's a little funky but you got to realize
that everybody nowadays has an opinion.
Everybody's a critic.
And, you know,
you can watch my video on
YouTube and leave a comment.
You can go to iTunes and buy
my album and leave a comment.
You can Tweet, whatever, you know.
And, you're going to drive yourself crazy
if you really take those things seriously.
Just, not everyone's going to love you.